[Musique]
quel plaisir de vous revoir civique
monsieur week
j'ai besoin de toi pour ce contrat je ne
suis plus cet homme là si tu es toujours
cet homme là je ne donnerai pas tu
connais les règles si tu ne la respecte
pas tu connais les conséquences
comptes créditeurs comment puis-je vous
aider je vous pris un coup à quel nom
john wick contrat est devenu
international il n'a aucune idée de ce
qui varie
par pitié que quelqu'un donne à 7
une arme
ramener l'encours du a poignardé le
diable dans le dos pour lui il ne s'agit
pas de vengeance mais de justice
du travail j'ai bien peur que oui
qui que ce soit je les tuerai
je les tuerai tous bien sûr que oui
il
je vais essayer mais je promets rien
[Musique]